phần qua được chính các thành gên đoàn Việt Nam chân thủ trên bị yêu vào buổi tối sau mỗi ngày là nhiều vụ tại hiện chân
mỗi phần qua của các đuều phần như khẩu trang, dễ bị sình lượng khẩu, mi ăn liền, hay thịt hộn
được lời trọng giữa trên lúc khẩu cấp thiết của người dân đặc sinh sống trong các khu tạm cờ
thế mà đoàn cũng tạc thì điều tưởng phạm bánh tị, phó cục chường của kêu hộ kêu nạn bộ tầm thăm mêu
chừng đoàn Việt Nam, tham gia khẩu khẩu khẩu khẩu đất tại vì thế này rơi là
đã cờ lời chia bộn sâu sắc tới người dân địa phương chục những mất mắt giò trên tại gây ra
thử tưởng phạm tị nhấn mạnh những phần qua tuy ra chỉ khẩu lớn, những chiếc đứng tình cá
xử xa chiếc của những dân Việt Nam đối với nơi đẹp với lá
theo thử tưởng phạm tị, bên nằm tâm trải qua nhiều cuộc chiến tranh, mở tình tại nên tấu hiểu những khó khẩu
mất mắt, mời gần bùng tháng hoạc đánh đối mặt, đồng thời tiến tưởng người dân bây nơi
thử ra sẽ xử vượt qua dài đoàn khó khán để ổn địa cuộc sống, mời gần tại cuộc tạm kư bây tỏ
xuất đọc chức sự quan tâm của đoàn tục tăng Việt Nam, các ơn những tình cá và sự hỗ trợ
kết thực trong bối cảnh cuộc sống vẫn còn nhiều thử thống sau tham hoạc, đây là một trong những hạt động
rất đoàn cục tắc kết nằm trên khai sống sống với những bụt tình kìm tương nạn tại vì thế này
bây ra, những người qua các cánh bộ trên xí Việt Nam linh tục làm việc với cường độ gão tại các khu vực độ gnar,
phố hợp cùng được lực kì hỗ sợ tạm và khu tế tìm kiếm các hạt nhé mất tích,
Nam thời, khổ trợ công tắc các phục hộ khó hợp đất